hi i'm melinda clark and i played julie
cooper nichol
hi i'm rachel bilson and i played summer
roberts summer roberts cohen
maybe i'll know c and we have a podcast
called welcome to the oc [ __ ]
i'm aheez i am a celeb
writer here at buzzfeed and also
certified oc superfan
to the point where when i was a kid i
asked my mom if we could celebrate
christma
and she said no because we are
protestant and black i look cool and
collected but internally i'm
freaking out and i am challenging them
to an
oc trivia quiz
here's how it'll work rachel and melinda
you guys will work together as a team
and i'll be taking it solo
we'll take turns and answering the
multiple choice questions
that none of us here have seen each
question we get correct is worth a point
but if one of us gets the question wrong
then the other team will have a chance
to steal the point
and then at the very end there's a bonus
question where we can wager
points and then whoever has the most
points at the end wins but we're all
winners here all right let's start
first question we all know luke's iconic
welcome to the oc
[ __ ] line but what does he say next
you're not in chino anymore
this is how it's done in orange county
you don't belong
in orange county why don't you go back
to chino
this is how it's done in orange county
in season one episode one when luke
famously says welcome to the oc
[ __ ] the next thing he says is this is
how it's done in orange county
where did ryan seth marissa and summer
go to school
the harbor school orange county prep
constance billard
harbor heights high thompson spiller was
gossip girl orange county prep
sounds fun and then harbor high tai
would watch that show it sounds
interesting but it's the harper school
ryan seth merson summer attended
the harbor school for high school which
of these actors did not
guest star on the oc shailene woodley
bella thorne kristen bell max
greenfield i know this one mindy do you
know it i think so but you tell us your
answer rachel
our girl kb did not guest star on the oc
correct
kristen bell shailene played the
original caitlyn cooper bella played
young taylor townsend
and max played young sandy cohen well
shailene played my daughter
she was so sweet very very smart
we will have to have all of them on the
podcast
[Laughter]
which of these seth and summer kisses
came first
the spiderman kiss the coffee cart kiss
the kiss
after seth recited i wish i was a
mermaid to summer
and the kiss at the charity event on the
boat the charity
event because i remember summer being
like oh no i like cohen
and he was like what and she's like i
wasn't talking to you okay i'm gonna go
with
the charity event no
yeah i wouldn't have known it had we not
re-watched it so it's a little bit of a
cheat but i believe it's the kiss after
seth recited i wish i was a mermaid to
summer
yeah correct after seth recited i wish i
was a mermaid to summer
season one episode six the charity event
kiss season one episode 10
the coffee cart kiss season one episode
20 spider-man kiss season 2
episode 14 all came after but i will say
the charity kiss
was very close so you were not that far
off i knew it's one of the two
this just gives me another reason to
rewatch season one
marissa's death scene was absolutely
haunting
what song was playing in this moment
hallelujah
by imogene heap hallelujah by jeff
buckley
hide and seek by imaging heap fix you
by coldplay what's funny is i know the
answer now but only because
we've looked into it further but for so
long i was like oh hide and seek by
image and heap was what playing in my
mind but like
now that i know because of the snl skit
dear sister
that was actually the shooting of trey
so the answer
is actually you know what right mindy
it's hallelujah by imogen heat correct
it was hallelujah sung by imogene heap
and i'm still not okay let's just say
i'm an imaging heap of tears y'all are
killing it
i mean it's a miracle that i know any of
i'm actually so surprised
which of these bands performed at the
bait shop
we have the white stripes the killers
rooney
franz ferdinand it's rooney i love
rooney still a huge fan of them though
if i get this wrong i'll be really
embarrassed
no what yeah i was gonna say
because they didn't play the bait shop
they played the concert
before the bait shop existed in your
defense that is confusing
i did the same thing and i was like wait
it's the killers
the killers performed at the bait shop
in season two episode four rooney
did also perform on the show but that
was in a different club in
season one because that was with oliver
trask
and i remember he was like i got vip
like tickets to go see rooney like in
the city
and everyone's like oh my god oliver
you're so amazing but he was like
not amazing what's the name of summer's
favorite tv show
i think we know that one we do know it
the valley
the bay the mountain the coast summer's
favorite show
is the valley the valley of course
i always wanted that to be a real show
oh me too like they kind of did that
something called the laguna beach and
then they did the hills
and what's ryan's birth mom's
first name fern don kelly
zayna pretty sure it's don mostly
because i just re-watched the series
finale
it's done i'm clicking on gone thank
goodness back on the board
let's do this when marissa has her
iconic freak out to julie poolside
where are they supposed to be heading
cotillion practice
the mall cardio bar or the nail salon
i happen to know this one because i was
actually doing real cardio bar
at the time correct they're on their way
to cardiovar but marissa unfortunately
makes them
late i was talking about this on a plane
sitting next to josh i was talking to
somebody about you need to come to
cardio bar with me
and he was writing a script and the next
thing you know
it was in the script yeah i remember
that scene where she just like screams
and i was like oh
she went for it and she was strong that
was that was she picked up that patio
furniture and whales oh yeah
she's like ye and like threw it into the
pool who appears in more episodes
summer roberts or julie cooper my gut
wants to say summer because summer's in
the core four
but also i almost want to lean towards
julie
because i know season one or at least
the first part of season one summer was
more recurring
but julie's always been like a presence
you know last time i was super sure
around something i clicked on rooney and
i got it wrong
so i'm gonna go with julie
summer appears in all 92 episodes while
julie appears
in 90. wow julie took off to go to paris
with kayla
came back with a haircut
and now we have our final bonus question
where we can wager points i have a
measly
two so i'm gonna major all two of my
points
how many points do we have y'all have
seven we'll be sweet [ __ ]
and save four thank you i appreciate it
okay
how many times does phantom planet say
california in the song california
whoever gets closer to the number wins
oh my god it's priced right now jeez
louise okay
i'm like singing the song in my head
california california
okay i have my guest 19 i'm gonna let
mindy guess for us
we're gonna say eight times drum roll
please
oh my gosh 18 is the answer
we love an underdog story and
i was the underdog mostly because rachel
and melinda were very gracious and
wagered a lot of points but the final
score ended up being
rachel and melinda three i got four
points
i'm going to be thinking about this day
for the rest of my life wow
congratulations hey
you did it thank you guys we have our
podcast welcome to the oc [ __ ]
new episodes out every tuesday wherever
you listen to your podcast if you want
to look at our faces
you can on youtube we hope you join us
and thank you so much
we'll see you soon
you